your daily commute right now may have
lighting like this but come Sunday
during daylight savings it gets darker
much earlier causing more dangers for
pedestrians
she crossed six Lanes of traffic and was
hit less than a yard from the curb it's
a problem April Stewart Grieves every
day November 2015 her 16 year old
daughter Mary Lilly hit and killed while
walking in a marked crosswalk during
daylight savings her mom says she was
headed home from the park he was going
41 miles per hour he was not speeding
and year to year officials say
pedestrian collisions and fatalities
worsen statistics from Metro Police show
nearly a hundred more pedestrian
collisions so far this year than all of
2021. in the state of Nevada we were
recently ranked 10th worst for
pedestrian fatalities in the country
Aaron Breen director of the road Equity
Alliance project says 51 pedestrians
have died just this year in Clark County
75 percent of these happening From Dusk
to Dawn it's very unfair Robert
Hutchinson with Southern Nevada Bicycle
Coalition saying 11 more bicyclists
without the needs of a car join that
list and as December approaches
historically the deadliest month for
Southern Nevada pedestrians Clark County
Commissioner Michael naft says old
pandemic driving habits have stuck
around they haven't readjusted their
driving patterns and then you also you
know the age-old problem here in
southern Nevada we have drivers from all
over the world that come here now even
past daylight savings they always urge
pedestrians to wear reflective clothing
at night drivers to always be alert and
aware when behind the wheel reporting
near Sunset and rainbow Ryan Matthey 8
News Now